and can you hear me now
is the question so
uh hopefully yes waiting for
confirmation
saying can't hear can't hear you she's a
mime
yeppy okay there we go
huh see it helps when you actually plug
the microphone
in i i find
and so so now like a [ __ ] i need to
reiterate my opening bit
may the fourth be with you
i don't know how many of you just
instinctively went and also with you but
i know you are out there
i know there are some of you so
enjoy that uh
is the force with me i have no idea
[Laughter]
i maybe
it's it's it's been um i don't know
it's been a very weird week it hasn't
been what it was supposed to be because
it was supposed to be
me focusing on basically only
the book and yet i ended up diving into
bad batch and you know it's it's become
and and i felt the need to make them a
video on doctor who related stuff that's
out tomorrow so i'm
not talking about that today uh so
you know it has not turned out uh as i
was
uh hoping that it would revenge of the
fifth
uh yeah depending on where you are time
zone wise it it is already
did you hear about the protests at uvm
well no i don't live anywhere near uvm
so i am unaware that there was one and i
have no idea what it's about
what's your first star wars memory okay
so
uh
here's the thing about me in star wars
my first memory is not
watching it for the first time i don't
remember
watching star wars for the first time
that's how young i was when i
started watching it my mother introduced
me to star wars
what i remember my earliest memory
regards to
these movies um was sitting on
the um i well i would usually sat
on the floor she'd sit on the couch uh
in our living room
at a house when i was when i was really
young and
she would it would start she would read
it out long times ago in the galaxy far
far away and we
when the title would come up we both
just yell star wars
and then she'd read the crawl to me
that is probably my earliest memory
relative to these movies
uh yep
uh to say that i've grown up on star
wars is quite
literal
it's been a weird week for me as well
didn't start off great but it's gotten
better hey
it's never too late for things to get
better uh
it was supposed to be me focusing in
there and lies the problem
it's not that i am incapable of focus
it's more well i guess that isn't
capable of
i'm it's i'm not good at extended
periods of focus i can focus in
bursts like back when i had a
quote unquote real job um about the
worst thing you could do is stick me in
a meeting that ran more than an hour
because no matter how hard i tried or
how good i faked it
uh mentally i was checked out
after about 55 minutes so if the
if the meeting wasn't wrapping up around
then
i was useless i just mentally completely
checked out so that's it
you can get about an hour out of me on
something that i don't have like a real
um serious passion for and even if i do
have that
maybe you get two hours out of me maybe
i might need a break like there's a
reason i miss
um going to movie theaters part of the
reason
that i really like going to the movies
is that
it removes distractions for me
you know i can't pause i can't go to the
kitchen and get a snack i can't
fiddle with my phone you know the room
is
there's literally nothing for me to do
other than stare at this
massive screen in the dark and watch the
movie and i appreciate that
forced focus to be completely honest
about it
um your mom sounds
awesome she is she is i was gonna notify
you regarding accusations against a
certain doctor who cosplayer
i noticed you were following on twitter
but his account is gone now
okay god's sake what is it
with the doctor who community now
because this is not the subject of
tomorrow's video but like
this is why i'm not really on twitter
like i am technically but like it's why
i don't really engage with twitter
as a platform because i feel like this
crap always seems to
happen there or blow up there or spiral
out of control there
and what was it like a week ago
okay i'm gonna have to explain this um
for anyone who doesn't know what the
hell went on
okay
so there was
a uh twitter
account that was built and designed as a
parody and a way to
just troll not my doctor
type whovians who just refused to accept
jody would occur
um in any way and
it was called nut my doctor and it
you know it gained a lot of popularity
among fans who aren't the not my doctor
types
to the point that the guy who ran a guy
named tom vance was kind of like he was
a little bit of a twitter golden boy
i guess and like i could so far as i can
tell he
did not have a presence in the fandom
outside twitter
so far as i would like that's kind of
what i mean when i say
i don't i don't mess with the damn
platform
very much um but
he turned out to be
not great um there's probably
more stuff that happened that like i'm
not even privy to the main thing that i
was aware
of was that um
he was in communication with a woman who
was a lesbian
and he basically kept saying something
to the effect of
i want i want to bone you
straight and things like that and
uh and i guess when that came out he
like sicked his fans onto her and then
it became a whole freaking
horrible toxic thing and so
while no i'm not now aware of a
cosplayer
on twitter that i followed on twitter
who is a mess
um you might want to let me know anyways
like shoot me a dm or something on
twitter because
it's possible i might be following them
on other platforms and that's the other
thing that i really
hate about being on something like
twitter and not really engaging with it
because the only reason i knew about
freaking tom vance was because somebody
notified me hey
you're currently following this guy and
here's what's going on with him
there's a lot of guilt by association on
a platform like twitter
you get judged for who you follow and
like that's not totally unfair
i mean hell i've done it one of my
earlier uh videos from over a year ago
criticizing jk rowling before she wrote
her
freaking turf wars essay
pointed out that she had publicly
followed an out and proud
transphobe and i judged her for that but
the thing is
you know a very easy thing to have
happen
on a platform like twitter is you start
following someone and at the time you
follow them everything seems fine but
then they turn
into horrible horrible human beings or
it
not turn into it turns out they are
horrible horrible human beings
later and if you're not plugged into the
platform and don't
realize that that happened
like me suddenly you can find yourself
you know
and thankfully this didn't happen like i
i got a heads up
that hey you probably might want to
think about i'm following this person
because
of xyz but it could have been very
possible that people would have just
started
hammering out on me telling me that i
was awful because i followed this person
and i wouldn't even know what the hell
was going on
stuff happens on twitter so fast
it honestly scares the crap out of me
to me it happens to a lot of fandoms
that get popular like anime
was at first an underground thing then
it gets huge then people who are creeps
move in
and ruin it for everyone ah
see i'm like i'm not going to
disagree with that necessarily
i am gonna say be careful about
um clinging to that narrative too much
because the narrative
that the bad elements of the fandom
are in somehow outsiders is
a narrative that is often used by
phantoms to not
deal with problems actually within their
core fandom
to just point at all the problem
elements and go well they're new here
like we're fine they're new and they're
the problem and like again i'm not going
to say that does not happen
but be careful about just
assuming that as a default and not
looking introspectively
at the people who have been there since
the beginning and being sure that they
are in fact
who you think they are so just be
careful that's all
which star wars film or show are you
most excited for
i'm i'm not
really um
i don't remember the last time i was
legitimately excited for
star wars was probably for the last
jedi honestly i i was
legitimately excited uh to see that
movie
i didn't like it um very much and
since then everything i've seen star
wars even some of the stuff that's like
been
pretty good i've i've gone into it being
like oh let's give it a shot
i've not been excited by star wars
uh in a while so i can't even remember
off the top my head all the stuff that
they are currently planning
i'd like i flat out cannot remember
because it's just not sticking in my
head
i i barely remembered that the bad batch
was happening
and i know there's more stuff planned
there's like there's something related
to boba fett that's happening
and ahsoka's going to get a spin out oh
the obi-wan thing's finally happening i
guess i i
if i'm gonna grade on a scale of i'm not
super excited about any of this i'm
probably
most curious about seeing the oboe the
oba one
obi-wan series that's probably what i
have the most interest
in at this point um but like i am
not uh at the at the height of my fandom
what you drinking i am drinking um water
dark and dry 802 water
bottled by woodchuck um
are you not even excited about the
mandolin i was never excited by the
mandalorian
even when i watched the first season i'm
like this is fine
yeah the mandalorian
i was curious about the first season
i was not blown away by it the way a lot
of people were blown away by it and
i'm not gonna say it's bad it's not and
i'm and i'm really glad that people
um people have liked it and taken to it
as much as they have especially since a
lot of the people who
ended up really liking that felt
underserved
by the um by the recent films
so i i mean i'm glad that those fans are
getting something that they
um can enjoy but
honestly i felt very very pandered too
and in a way i didn't really care for um
with the man with the mandalorian and in
a way that like
there's a bunch of stuff that bugs me
about the mandalorian that
really does not seem to bother anybody
else on the planet
but it still bothers me
and like just gets in my head i'm like
that
it's stupid crap like here's
here's a perfect example of what i'm
talking about because this is a tiny
detail
that does not matter at all
and it ticked me off and annoyed me
so in i'm pretty sure the very first
episode
of uh the mandalorian when he goes to
meet
with um werner herzog whatever the heck
his character
was named um the the little ball
comes out the same kind of droid
door thing pops out
that was on jabba's palace in return of
the jedi
that in and of itself that's fine it's
like some kind of
you know it's a droid doorbell you know
thing kind of basically
and that's totally fine with me what
annoyed the heck out of me is
though is that its dialogue is exactly
the exact
same dialogue that it says
in return of the jedi now it's
untranslated maybe they thought that's
why they could get away with it
but the fact that that door droid says
the exact same thing
in the exact same tone with the exact
same cadence
really annoyed me because
as far as i'm concerned other than the
battle droids
those are really the only ones i'll give
a pass to to me
what's so amazing about the droids and
star wars is that they have
personalities that they are unique and
that little door thing at jobs pals
felt like it had a personality it laughs
at c-3po and r2d2
but to find out that it's cadence and
and lines and personality are just some
default program thing that they all say
that really annoyed me it made it
less cool it made it less special
and again this is tiny
and stupid and petty
as hell
but the whole show was loaded with stuff
like that
you know stuff that i'm pretty sure was
supposed to make me smile that instead
just made me groan
and i think that like at its core that's
what
to me bad pandering feels like
they're trying to go ooh remember this
and i'm going yeah i do
recreating it doesn't endear me to you
so yeah
i still haven't seen the second season
of the mandalorian i should find out
when they're doing a third season
because
maybe i'll marathon the second season
before the third one comes out
no promises on that
oh pirates uh happy birthday i did see
that it scrolled past me
i'm here to rattle off some more
nitpicks about the mandalorian
i'll have one more for you um but first
erica koshar you get a heart for the
super chat thank you
so very very much just giving you an
overdue tip
from the deep dives i've taken into your
video archives since discovering your
channel this year
may the fourth be with you thank you
erica thank you very much
now i'm curious as like to how deep have
you gone because like
at a certain point like there there are
distinct eras
like you go back more than a couple of
years and the video quality
just the general visual quality drops
immensely because it was on my old
camera
and then like you see different setups
there was the time when i was trying to
use the green screen i'm like oh god how
far back how far back is she going
um i presume she based off the name hope
hope that was all right um
so um
yeah okay you asked for another nitpick
from the mandalorian
it really annoyed me seeing the land
speeder the exact same model land
speeder that we saw on tatooine
on an ice planet
i let me be clear and the
this one this nitpick is twofold
layer one while there's absolutely no
reason
that these same things cannot appear on
multiple planets
somehow that makes their appearance on
tatooine
a little bit less special because my
assumption going in
was largely that outside of the empire
which obviously standardizes its
equipment
and made to some degree
excuse me vehicles that travel between
worlds and are all going to need certain
things i had
always kind of assumed that the
technology was kind of homegrown on any
given planet
and that it wasn't going to be exactly
the same going from planet to planet
from one to another so to see the exact
same land speeder not only on a
different planet
but on ice
goes from a desert planet to an ice
planet works just as well i'm like
so now this is just the generic land
speeder that is on every planet
across the galaxy and it makes the
galaxy seem smaller
and more uniform and less interesting
and again that is stupid
and petty you are welcome
um somebody asked my favorite um star
wars theme
i'm uh i'm partial to the
um
to what i think of as the force theme
that might be its official name i cannot
remember
the especially when it's played with the
with the binary sunset
and that build do do do
do do do do that one
further news regarding blade in the
recent marvel reveal trailer
starting to get dark universe vibes i'm
not
um
i i did i did marvel drop something else
i saw that thing that they dropped
i think yesterday um which choked me up
because the use of stan lee's voice for
some reason really choked me up with
that
but i'm i'm still on board for marvel
i'm i'm really interested to see what
they're gonna do
and um it's been
it's been a joy realizing
how much oh just over time
the mcu has kind of warmed its way into
my heart and just realizing how
capable it might be of
um of moving me if it
if it can hit the right notes and
sometimes it does it doesn't always
but sometimes it does question regarding
my favorite part of any star wars movie
favorite lightsaber duel favorite
lightsaber duel is
luke versus vader in
uh return of the jedi i love
that one for two reasons
um and no ms wicked wolf i don't do
cardio i don't do aerobics so i love
that um
that fight for two different reasons
um first of all
i love the emotional weight of it
like the my big issue with
for instance say the prequel um
lightsaber fights was
that as cool as they looked i was very
emotionally detached from them
because it was just
skill against skill and that's not
uninteresting at its best that can be
quite whoa
but for me a fight needs to have
for it to be truly great needs to have
an emotional investment
and i felt really emotionally invested
in the confrontation between luke
and um and darth vader
and to to see especially like that
moment where
luke is trying to hide and vader goads
him out
by basically um threatening to try and
turn leia to the dark side instead and
luke snaps and goes in and just starts
wailing on i love that he beats vader
not with finesse but just by
beating him down and i
love the mute i feel like this is an
underappreciated track
the music in that it's this coral bit
and
usually i feel like these days when you
get a coral aspect
to a film's score it's usually
you know sort of more and more on the
mid and the upper range
but this one it's so deep it's like
bases like
it's like it's almost like the like the
tibetan throat scene it's like this low
deep guttural as as they're fighting ah
it's so good it's so good
i love that fight i love it to death
um for just coolest and best visual
would
honestly probably go to the throne room
fight in
the last jedi because i don't care who
you are that fight owns
oh erica erica again
all right what do we got the dive has
been so deep
i'm forking over a little more oh my
goodness
i like the progression of the videos
from someone discovering their voice to
more professional content
and she it's she you got it right that's
a relief oh
thank you um see now i'm i'm curious
um you you don't have to super chat me
again i'll i'll watch for you if you
answer this um but i i am
now kind of curious as to um
whether you have like gone back to the
beginning or coming forward or are you
working for the bag of like watching a
de-evolution
of of my presentation and
uh and style i'm weird and i fully admit
my favorite is mace windu
versus darth sidious huh
interesting choice
correct me if i'm wrong your tick tock
live stream said
you said the the gnome king
his minions and the wheelers from return
dollars creeped you out they did
not on a nightmare level but yeah they
did
uh your video archive is like classic
doctor who
can't wait until you don colin baker's
coat and
start strangling
nope
can you impersonate roger rabbit yeah
kind of i really don't want to though
i know what vera was talking about vader
got the beating of his
life well second b town the first was
when uh obi-wan got the higher ground
yeah you can't beat the higher ground
i remember that that became such a meme
um like i
i remember things like
um you know people laying out cards in
like a game of magic gathering then
somebody just played a
card that said the high ground it's like
that's it i win
i have the high ground
if the mandalorian isn't your thing what
would you like to see more
of from star wars i'm tell you what what
i'm curious
on um excited would be an overstatement
but i am
curious is the uh
the one that's gonna follow oh god i
can't think i can
suddenly i cannot think of the actor nor
the character's name but the the guy who
was like the spy type in rogue one
that's gonna follow him
because it would be interesting to me to
see more of that
side of
excuse me of the conflict
um because you know we've seen
the noble jedi we have seen
the space battles and pilots we have
seen troopers versus droids
we haven't seen this a ton of the sneaky
gorilla tactics
of the spies
the people who are going to work dirty
to get the job done
who aren't going to get medals at the
end of this i i'm curious to see what
they'll do with that
and that's kind of my main thing i i
would like
i i would really like that
if they would explore more
different aspects of this
universe and of the conflicts that we've
already seen
in it um because
i i could go the rest of my life without
seeing another jedi
like honestly i don't need to see a jedi
again
it's shocking to me that we have yet to
get a series that
really zeros in on and like doesn't just
skirt around the edge of or touch them
but like it really dives into the
underworld
closest we've gotten really at least
that i've seen is the han solo movie
which isn't
great but i would
like to see something that more dwells
in that world
in that underbelly because it's
fascinating and it keeps being something
that
star wars touches on and doesn't
really connect with
uh not that deep anyways
so i think that's that's where i i've
got
um a lot of frustrations with star wars
right now
is they keep circling back to the
st to the skywalker family which i'm
also done with
and to jedi into the empire and like
there's so many things that we get
glimpses of
and that get touched on across
these the these movies that i would love
to see deeper dives in
and even if we get it eventually i'm
gonna end up being
frustrated that it's taken this long to
really start to dive into those things i
mean part of the reason i liked rogue
one was that
more so than any of the other movies it
felt like a war
movie um you know as a genre
not an adventure but a harrowing war
movie where
everybody dies so i i
want them to step out of
some of the trappings that they're
really stuck in because you can set
something in this universe
and you don't need jedi you don't need
stormtroopers you don't need
all these specific things you can still
do so many things that will still make
it
feel like star wars
but have it bring in new stuff or just
explore other corners of it better
uh note an empire that vader says
obi-wan has taught you well right after
luke takes the high ground
[Laughter]
i love that
what do you think of the upcoming leslie
headland high republic series before the
prequels the acolyte oh that is probably
the thing i have the
least interest in um anytime
anytime that um
i've looked at anything star wars
related that deals with well
prior to the empire i'm bored
immediately
i find the i find the old republic
or even the high republic or whatever i
find it
so boring and i find it doubly boring
for the fact that it seems like
technology never changes
in star wars i remember like flipping
through
a star wars comic or something and you
know and there's
starships and lightsabers and
you know blasters and it says it takes
place a thousand years before this
the the um proper
trilogy and i'm like i'm sorry what
so there's a there's a static-ness that
it that i feel whenever they go back
further in time and i just don't
care i don't care
stop going back go to the side give me
this give me
side quills it's kind of where i'm at
with these things
um at this point
uh i think i came in
this is erica following up i think i
came in at the middle i
i watched by topics that interested me
at first then was like
who is this cool cat and started to
watch the archive
cool cat i am indeed a hoopy fruit
um disney's gotta make a sequel to
enchanted what are your thoughts i don't
love the title and i don't love the
starting pitch because the title is
disenchanted
and the log line that they
put out really seems to indicate that
gizelle has become jaded by the real
world i think the very idea of that
happening
misunderstands her character so
badly that i am really skeptical of
having any interest in this
at all i mean i'll wait for a trailer um
we'll see how that goes but
i i tell ya
palpatine would be when vader picked him
up
i have the high ground
oh that really that really does make a
for a good running gag
um jimmy jonathan lee
thank you for the super chat you get a
heart my friend
any thoughts on the more positive
critical reevaluation of the prequel
trilogy in recent years also
um hopefully have a nice spring um
i mean i i always figured that would
happen eventually
if only because there was a whole
generation
uh younger than me who grew up on the
prequel trilogy and eventually
we're going to become old enough and
well versed enough in film and criticism
to be able to articulate
what it was that they liked about it um
because i think there was an assumption
from fans
well my age and older was that
like all the younger siblings or younger
cousins or whatever that we knew who
liked
the prequels would grow up uh later on
and go
wow can't believe i ever thought those
were good boy was i dumb and you know
what they didn't cause that's not
how that's not how uh nostalgia works
but don't take my saying nostalgia as to
think that they are blinded by nostalgia
sometimes nostalgia
can make you realize the value of
something more so than someone who
doesn't have that
and it will invigorate you to dive in
deeper as to why you like it and to find
the good and pull that out
so i'm not surprised it's getting a
critical re-evaluation
i don't think my views are ever really
going to change the only one i
i suppose at some point i really should
re-watch the clone wars
because that's the only star wars
prequel that i've only seen
once i almost said that's the only star
wars movie i've only seen once that's
not true anymore that was true once upon
a time
but i've only seen solo once i've only
seen
rise of skywalker once i've only seen
the last jedi once
complete i've seen bits and pieces of it
since then
just to kind of reaffirm that no i
really don't like it
um but yeah it's i mean it's it's nice
it's fine i doubt
my personal views will um
will ever really change oh tracy
tracy dale thank you very much
for the super chat um i have
loved the mandalorian star uh star wars
property i've gotten the most pure
enjoyment out of since the original
trilogy but different strokes oh
absolutely
like like i said at the beginning of
that whole
multi-part ramble on my nitpicks about
the mandalorian i'm
really happy that that there are people
who are really enjoying it
um especially knowing that there's that
um on the venn diagram
of people who uh liked
uh mandalorian and didn't like the last
jedi
or maybe didn't like the latest trilogy
at all that there's a lot of crossover
in that venn diagram um so i
i appreciate that those people
didn't get alienated off the franchise
as a whole because aside from the ones
who were just
kind of weird
[ __ ] about it you know who they were
other than that like that there's a lot
of legitimate
fan dispiritment if that's a word
um after the last jedi came out
so knowing that that kind of fan is
um getting something that they like more
or that any fan like really enjoys it
that's great
that's fantastic so i i would never
make a case that i don't think i'd make
a case that any of these movies
are movies that people shouldn't like i
only ever give the reasons why
i don't like them so i'd like to see a
series where a war criminal hunting
force uh basically a space mossad
go after julian glover's character from
empire
huh interesting
actually that is kind of so like
the idea of um
of like how all the the all there were
long extended decades-long hunts for all
these nazi war criminals after world war
ii
oh that's actually a really good pitch
oh dang rowan like
solid wow i like that a lot
ah you should watch the clone wars
series
i'm sure i i'm sure i should i've heard
it's very good i've heard it starts out
rocking it gets better
i just don't have time i mean that's why
i jumped in on bad batch it's
just starting so it's not a massive
amount of homework for me to catch up on
so that's why i felt okay to start there
uh loved your bad batch video and would
like to point out that
if you haven't seen already that echo is
returning clone
wars character who is a large part of
their clone wars arc
i mean like i i didn't know the
specifics of that but like they explain
in the bad batch that he is new to this
group like i got all that they explained
all that
i still don't really fully understand
his function within the group and i
really don't understand his narrative
function right now
maybe they'll find one for him but he
feels superfluous at the moment
so it's not like it's not like i don't
understand where it came from
narratively i do it's
just you know the structure and
the law of the economy of characters i
don't know why he's there
obi-wan add a cook out so i had the high
ground and then he screamed i
hate you and then he was all like this
lay steak on the grill oh breathing
nerdum that is
that is cold and harsh and i respect it
uh jj abrams is gonna produce oh the
places you'll go
as in the dr seuss book
[Music]
don't turn
dr seuss
into movies
stop
none of them are any good
the closest to a good movie
is the animated how the grinch stole
christmas
but that is a short that is not long
enough to qualify as a movie
nothing that dr seuss ever wrote
was ever designed to work for an
hour and a half
and trying to stretch those stories and
what made those stories fun and
wonderful
into an hour and a half is going to
break
them and it has
every time and before somebody quotes
seussical at me
keep in mind that that is a a stage
musical different standard for
suspension of disbelief first of all and
second of all
is pulling from dozens of different
books
to cobble its story together
i'm annoyed now
emperor tries to blow up pendor moon he
walks reverse sue no card
oh the reverse call warner brothers is
gonna make cat in the hat movie yeah of
course they are
of course they frickin are
rant about something of your choice go i
just did
uh the grinch had carrie and horton were
okay no they
no they're not okay they're bad
how bad they look i see people give a
pass
to the jim carrey grinch and even the
benedict cumberbatch grinch and horton
hears the who
the only reason you would ever give them
a pass to these things if you are
grading them on a curve
because you are looking at how bad these
things
can be and basically looking at cat in
the hat and going
well it's not that bad and so going well
it must be good no it can still be
bad they're all bad
they're not good if you like them
that's fine you can like them but i will
not accept the possibility that they are
good movies because they're
not especially as representations of
their core material which is how i'm
going to judge them
because i grew up on these stories i
love these stories to death
and i will always look at these as how
did they
bring the core themes of the original to
the screen
did they preserve them did they twist
them did they break them and they
all screw it up every time
all of them and you can find redeeming
features
in some of them depending on what it is
that worked for you
but they all suck
as adaptations of dr seuss because the
very idea
of a feature-length adaptation of dr
seuss should get you
shut down at the door
if you show up and say hey i want to
make a 90 minute to two hour movie based
on a dr seuss book
you should be laughed out of the room
not give it a sack of money
okay
vader the power of the force is
insignificant compared to plot armor
[Laughter]
uh the ability to destroy a planet
is insignificant next to the power of
the high ground
something positive now data sherlock
holmes go it's just adorable
is what that is that's just that's just
so cute it's the cutest egg thing
seeing data do cosplay it's adorable
have you seen a studio ghibli movie uh
check my um
older videos i did a ranking of all of
miyazaki's directed movies i have not
seen every ghibli movie but i have seen
every miyazaki directed movie
illumination is just d-grade pixar it
goes pixar disney dreamworks
illumination
uh they want to make an animated feature
of the giving tree for god's sake their
standards don't exist oh anybody
well first of all nobody should be doing
that um
i will put disney above pixar in that
ranking
but i know i'm in the minority on that
so how much money would you need to
watch the star wars holiday special
it's what an hour long
realistically just the usual 60
for commission review i couldn't justify
charging more
how long have you known that universal
was gonna make the wicked movie oh
they've been talking about
doing that for oh my god over a decade
like they they keep they keep it's been
in development hell forever
so like me knowing that is not insider
knowledge
that's just you know me being old and
having kept an eye on movie news for a
long time
[Laughter]
uh i heard velma's getting a female love
interest in scooby-doo
i don't know whether i'm excited or
confused i'm not confused
i'm i don't know why you need to do love
interest in scooby-doo at
all like you go back and
watch the originals it's not even clear
that fred and daphne
are dating like that's just an
assumption people make
so i don't know
uh will james earl jones
become vader with disney money
i mean they've got the funds
over two decades actually oh they just
uh thank you thank you for reminding me
how old i am
uh up yours
ah one of my friends are following you
on instagram i don't
update instagram that much so i
i hope they don't feel too disappointed
random comic facts
currently in marvel comics eddie brock
is venom again
all right they go back and forth on that
as he has a son named dylan
who is half symbiote because of venom
uh
i'm not gonna rule out the possibility
that you could get good stories out of
that
but i would be lying if i didn't say
that my gut reaction to that is that
sounds really dumb
um i was in a youth theater production
of seussical i was the mayor of whoville
uh my kid was in uh was in a uh
youth production of seussical
i'll be i don't know she
she did i think she did three
years of participating
i think it was three it was at least two
of participating in the local
children's theater in the summer
and with how long it's been
i i wonder if she's going to
yes heroin discord thank you i will get
to that um in just a minute
i i wonder if
she still has an interest in theater i
honestly don't know
i don't know subs or dubs when it comes
to anime dubs unless it sucks
unless the dub flat out sucks i will
always do dubs because
i feel like i'm not seeing what i'm
supposed to be seeing when i have to
stare at the bottom two inches of the
screen
now i won't do dubs on live action
that's only anime
my daughter follows you on tick-tock um
how old's your daughter cuz
i'm not as all ages friendly
on tick tock as as i am
here or at least i try to be here
so
um oh connor i i've got a couple of
super chat a couple super chats and then
carol and i will check the discord
promise let me just uh let me just
deal with these so connor
you get a heart excuse me
do you know the song rather be by clean
bandit
i don't think so
hang on i can't play it because if i
play it i'm gonna
um oh here we go
um
[Music]
uh rather
be
somebody clear planet let me get let me
pull up lyrics
oh no no i do know that song yeah that
song's fun
i enjoy that uh jimmy jonathan
lee you get a heart
in hindsight i'm surprised there's so
much negativity towards the concept of
midichlorians does it remove the
mysticism of the force
i kind of like it well yeah it does
it part of what was really cool about
the force
was the universality
of it that it was so vague that it could
be anything and then to bring it down
to biology uh
i don't know and even if it's not
even if it doesn't like remove the
mysticism for you
it's just like why why would you take
something that is nebulous to the point
of
just giving you a hell of a lot of
freedom to do whatever you want with it
and go oh it's these microscopic
organisms in your blood
like why why why would you do that
okay i gotta check the um
the discord so let me pull
that up a reminder the council of geeks
discord is a
patreon exclusive perk
and so if you want access to that and
it's a way to guarantee that i will
address your
questions without having to drop me the
super chats but let me just pop on over
there see what we've got
um live stream question have you shown
your kid ghostbusters looking back
it's one of those films like a lot of
80s that's a bit racier
than sometimes remembered such as ray
and the dream ghost um my kid actually
has seen ghostbusters
i don't think she remembers it that well
and she liked the cartoon more anyways
the thing is though while there is a
fair amount of that like
it just goes over kids heads like and it
went over my head
when i was a kid and watched that i
didn't know what was going on i was just
like that's weird whatever and moved on
like it didn't stick in my head as like
oh that was so weird and taboo and i
shouldn't have seen that
like maybe i shouldn't have i don't know
but yeah no she has
yes she saw it once um and like even the
cartoon which she did enjoy for a while
she grew out of that a few years ago so
um i mean at this point i think she
barely remembers who the ghostbusters
are truth told and also my friend and i
uh have your stream on as i shave their
head
felt like mentioning this because it's
their first time with short hair and
they're very excited
yes that's why the questions are so slow
going on the actual stream
they wanted me to ask you for geeky or
nerdy things to watch or get involved in
that are trans and lgbtq plus friendly
oh i really one of these days i need to
come up
with uh with a recommendation list for
that
because unfortunately part of what's
frustrating is so
many um lgbtq plus
um stuff that connects with a lot of us
it's allegorical
because it's still
now very rare for us to get depicted
openly in these things so
you know from an allegorical standpoint
whether or not you want to watch these
because of director brian singer this is
fair but
um like x2 i think works really well
allegorically
um as a queer narrative
i connected an awful lot to the shape of
water
you know speaking to my own um queer
experience
a lot connected with that um
but as far as like the big franchises go
there isn't a lot to hold on to and you
have to kind of
you have to kind of find themes that you
connect with
um that
relate that way to you but aren't
addressing it directly because most of
them don't
as far as trans and lgbtq friendly at
least in terms of not depicting but at
least not being negative towards it
most current running franchises are
pretty good about that
because of what a bad look it is so
uh it's really not until you get back
into the earlier 2000s definitely when
you start getting into the 90s and the
80s
it can get diceier um
but things for the most part are it's
much more rare for anything to be
openly hostile these days which
you know that's a start
oh what have i got i've got oh femme fun
time
love the name you get a heart
for the super chat what would your
custom lightsaber look like
i you know what
i need to i need to like
i say i need to i don't need to but i
want to like get into
whatever store they've got at the star
wars experience at disney world
where you can get a custom lightsaber i
just want to start i just want to i need
to
get handle i need to get handles in my
hand and
find a grip that really speaks to me and
i think that's going to be step one
and then depending on what that grip is
i feel like i will
get pulled to a certain color depending
on what that grip looks and feels like
if that makes any sense uh
i always felt the x-men works for an
allegory for kids with special needs
x-men actually works as an allegory for
a lot of things um
that second x-men movie in particular
though x2 x-men united
did make the link to the queer
experience pretty explicit
that's not to say that that's what it
has to represent because the the x-men
the whole idea of the mutants and how
that works um
can speak to a lot of marginalized
experiences it can
speak to racism to neurodivergence to
lgbtq plus
to all sorts of things so
that's one of the things that's really
cool about it as a concept and just
how versatile it is in terms of the
kinds of
issues it can it can address either
directly or
allegorically excuse me
how'd your first vaccine go my arm hurt
i had to sleep
i had to be careful what side i slept on
um
because my arm hurt for two solid days
after that
uh what is the most popular classic film
that is now seen as openly hostile
towards lgbt people
and goes or jumped in besides ace
ventura
ace ventura might possibly be the worst
that in terms of
open hostility
but
there's a lot of others that
they're not openly hostile but there are
still problematic
so like the original psycho
silence of the lambs these are not
openly hostile and
actually in terms of the text of the
works
are even do some things to try and
mitigate the damage
but they still um either established or
did a lot to reinforce
some views and stereotypes that are
dangerous
even though i wouldn't call either of
those films openly
hostile um
but yeah ace ventura is openly hostile
flatly there there really is no two ways
about
that one that oh
that first movie is gross and it
kind of skis me that i used to think it
was funny as a kid like it would lose me
by the end like i just wasn't finding
the humor as funny and that stuff
towards the end i just
i didn't understand why it was funny
um or why anyone thought it was i wasn't
offended by it i just like
okay what but yeah
uh in addition to the special edition i
really like close the blast doors close
the blast doors
open the blast doors open the blast
doors uh that was so weird to me because
the open the blast doors
the second part that was always in the
movie but they added
you know they're running the hallway
close the blast doors like why
like we see them close obviously
somebody closed them
and like the open the blast doors was
funny because they it was like oh for
god's sake just let us through
we almost had them but like adding that
line at the front end was
so weird i don't know why they did that
um do you like the band journey yeah
they're fine
i like a couple of their songs um bill
and ted's excellent adventure uses the f
slur
it does it does and you know it's really
jarring when that happens
because it seems so out of place with
how
sweet that movie is it
it jolts you out of it and kind of just
speaks to the time that
people don't at the time people just did
not
think it was a big deal and so in this
family
aimed family-friendly shockingly
wholesome movie that doesn't even really
have a villain
they still drop that word ah
yeah all right i am gonna wrap it up
soon i'm not gonna run
uh i'm not gonna run long this time
because i do have stuff to do i need to
get back to book
related stuff rocky horror still holds a
place in my heart but yeah it's a little
problematic oh no it definitely is
i i love rocky horror and i will
i will praise it to my death
i will not necessarily defend it
there's a difference between praising
something and defending it because there
are a ton
of issues with it if you're looking at
it from a representation angle
i will still praise it to high heaven
personally but i will not really defend
it against those criticisms
so there you go uh to me x-men first
class works great as a story about
marginalized groups
uh with the whole no more hiding idea
and you know a lot less brian singer
which we all need less brian singer i
agree with
part of that but i really didn't care
for first class that much
i didn't think it was that interesting
and you know
the only um heroic mutant they kill is
the black guy
even when i first watched it i was like
wait what
i don't know so
i am going to wrap it up
so i hope everybody had fun i hope
everybody had
a good uh may the fourth
uh the fourth may be coming to an
end but the force will be with you
always
ah so hope everybody has a good
rest of the week and um take care of
yourselves
please remember that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved you're the council
i'm just running the meeting and until
next time this council
is adjourned
execute order 66.